Speaker 1: Hey, we have the political media
equivalent of Kim Jong un and Hitler having
a baby.
The My Pillow CEO, Michael Andell is now supporting
Alex Jones Infowars conspiracy show.
Michael and Dels.
Mike Pillow is now running ads on Infowars.
He's offering an Alex Jones promo code.
And Alex Jones talked about pillows and sheets
and all these different things.
It's absolutely wild.
But but this is something the right has that
the left doesn't and the right is better off
for it.
Now, I'll explain what I mean by that in a
moment.
If you're not familiar with Mike Lyndell and
or Alex Jones, Alex Jones is a major conspiracy
theorist.
Infowars is his platform, his channel.
He has been banned from YouTube.
He's been banned from a bunch of different
platforms for regularly peddling all sorts
of conspiracy theories, including specific
ones that are so specific about individuals
that it has ruined some people's lives.
It has ruined people's lives when they become
the target or the focus of the ire of Alex
Jones audience, Alex Jones has sometimes had
to apologize.
There have been lawsuits, et cetera.
He's been kicked off a bunch of platforms.
Similarly, Mike Lyndell, almost like a match
made in heaven.
I don't know or hell, depending on your perspective.
Mike Lyndell also pushing all sorts of conspiracy
theories, claiming that he has found voting
machines, which he has in his possession,
which prove that even California was actually
won by Donald Trump.
He's insisted Trump would be reinstated in
March and then May and then most recently
August.
Although he might be off by a month, it might
actually be September.
So now they are together.
Here is Alex Jones promoting.
It's so pathetic, various sheets and pillows
and even towels.
If you can imagine,
Speaker 5: you've got your amazing towel packed.
It's, what, one hundred nine dollars for thirty
nine ninety five with promo code Alex.
Bring in any money there.
People should purchase it there to fund what
you're doing, they should help buy one hundred
nine dollars, but thirty nine ninety five.
I'm not sure that's a huge discount by you.
And I'm told all other products, up to sixty
six percent off the promo code.
Alex.
So promo code, the act at my pillow dot com.
And I'm just super excited to tell my listeners
to go support you and get great products,
because if they don't fund this war effort,
if they don't back this up and pray for us
to spread the word and support us financially,
the globalists are going to win.
So, again, people got to put fuel in your
tank.
You are taking the global stand toe to toe.
And if we don't energize you, well, then we
deserve to lose.
So so tell folks about these these amazing
towel's I know you want to do.
Seven weeks ago, you said this to me.
Tell us about the towels, the sheets, all
the products.
Well, the towels are the best house in history.
They actually dry you.
They don't you don't feel like the ones that
talk like all laundry.
They work.
These are the towels you seen on TV, the best
towels ever.
Speaker 1: Isn't that just an incredible deal,
guys?
And you can tell Alex Jones really loves these
products, but he also points out, you know,
you've got to buy this stuff to support the
fight against the globalists.
It's a political thing.
The towels and the sheets are really shocking.
I mean, doctors have looked at these and they
just can't believe what these towels are able
to do.
But it's not just that the towels are great.
There's a political reason that you have to
buy them, and that is to fight globalists.
Now, this is the very same Michael Lyndell,
who, when appearing as a guest, said he thinks
Trump actually won California, not Joe Biden.
Trump's going to be reinstated again by some
mechanism that is unknown to us and to anybody
else who understands how elections work and
how the constitution works.
And just consider the sort of groups that
have been brought together under the delusions
of Trump ism, people who would normally never
want to be around each other, even for a second.
At the top level.
As I've said before, Trump's followers are
overwhelmingly the people that Trump was disgusted
by most of his life as a rich New Yorker,
Trump grew up in a bubble in which, you know,
the the farmers who go to his rallies in Iowa,
the boater's with the little outboard motors
who boated to his rally when he did one who
knows where in Florida during these are people
Trump wanted to isolate and insulate himself
from his entire life.
That match is already weird.
But, you know, even like the militia gun types
and then the big city conspiracy theorists
who never would own a gun and then the anti
VAX nuttery, people all over the place, people
that have been brought together in some sense
by the campaign and the political presence
of Donald Trump and Michael Mandel and Mike
Pelo now with Mike my pillow, not Mike Pillow,
now brought together sponsoring Fox News and
Tucker Carlson for a long time sponsoring
Steve Bannon's one America.
But you know, Steve Bannon's War Room and
One America News and Rightside broadcasting
all this stuff.
And then now also Alex Jones and Infowars
Lyndell is really has bought his way into
being one of the most influential anti vaccine
conspiracy theorists out there.
He's called the vaccines the mark of the beast
on multiple occasions and a guy continuing
to foment the election lies and conspiracy
theories.
And then, on the other hand, Alex Jones infamous
9/11 truthers, so-called Sandy Hook conspiracy
theorist, has promoted conspiracy theories.
I think about Chobani yogurt at one point
and Alex Jones conspiracy theories go from
just very stupid to very, very dangerous.
And he's carried out harassment campaigns,
et cetera.
So they are mostly getting away with this
stuff without consequences.
Yes, Alex Jones has had to apologize a couple
of times.
His lawyers have had to go to court and do
that pathetic thing where they say, listen,
he's an entertainer, much like Tucker Carlson
and Fox News lawyers have said about Tucker,
he's using hyperbole and exaggeration.
You don't this isn't news in the literal sense.
Alex Jones lawyers have had to do the same
thing.
But big picture, there have not been real
consequences.
Michael Mandel has become very wealthy with
this stuff.
Alex Jones has become relatively wealthy,
although we don't know exactly what the financial
situation is right now because of all of the
legal trouble, there is no real equivalent
to this on the left.
And when I say that, I mean two things.
There's no real equivalent to this on the
left from the standpoint of the level of unhinged
nuttery that is this prominent.
There's conspiracy theories on the left.
There's no doubt they don't become prominent
like this, but they.
Also benefit on the right, because having
funders like Michael Lyndell, that will just
throw money at everything, they'll throw money
at Bannen, they'll throw money at whoever,
you know, all of these people.
Alex Jones, this gives them a leg up.
It does.
And Alex Jones, thanks to his supplement sales
as well, is now being funded by my pillow,
is able to continue producing the propaganda,
whereas in other circumstances, he might really
be having trouble by virtue of having lost
the YouTube platform, et cetera.
So it's good for them.
And I say that cynically.
It gives them a leg up and that's why you
continue to see a lot of this stuff spread.
Let me know your thoughts about that big funding
difference that the left just doesn't have
it.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this